en el último vídeo estuvimos trabajando
con esto que tengo aquí multiplicamos
dos tercios por seis es decir una
fracción por un número entero y nos
dimos cuenta que había dos formas de
entenderlo la primera era tomarme la
suma consigo mismo de dos tercios seis
veces es decir esta parte que tengo aquí
tomarme dos tercios más dos tercios más
dos tercios más dos tercios seis veces y
con esto llegamos el resultado de cuatro
o en su dado caso lo que podíamos hacer
era tomarme dos terceras partes de estos
seis enteros
es decir dividir al 6 entre 3 y lo
multiplicaba por 2 y llegaba también al
4 en este vídeo lo que quiero ver es
cómo podemos entender la multiplicación
de una fracción por una fracción así que
para esto déjame subir un poco toda esta
pantalla de aquí no lo vamos a necesitar
justo ahorita
déjame subir esta parte de aquí y vamos
a trabajar con la multiplicación de
fracciones entonces imagínate que esta
vez necesita multiplicar tres cuartos
tres cuartos por
por a un medio por
ok y lo primero que podemos concluir es
que esto es exactamente lo mismo justo
por lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado que
un medio que un medio multiplicando
multiplicando a tres cuartos a tres
cuartos ahora bien para entender bien
qué significa tomarme tres cuartos y
multiplicarlo por un medio o al revés
tomarme un medio y multiplicarlo por
tres cuartos
voy a intentar explicártelo de una
manera visual así que intentemos hacer
aquí una recta numérica intentemos hacer
aquí una recta numérica más o menos por
acá y esta recta numérica
va a tener aquí al cero me voy a tomar
justo aquí al cero y hasta acá me voy a
tomar al 1 por acá me voy a tomar al 1 y
bueno esta recta crece para acá y si yo
quiero tomarme primero un medio
medio de este entero pues bueno tendría
que dividir a este entero justo a la
mitad que es más o menos por aquí aquí
tengo a un medio de lujo ahora tomarme
tres cuartos por un medio es exactamente
lo mismo que tomarme tres cuartos de
este un medio así que para eso lo que se
me ocurre es dividir a este medio a este
un medio en cuatro partes iguales y es
más vamos a dividir todo el entero de
tal manera que cada una de estas mitades
esté dividida en cuatro partes iguales
así que vamos a hacerlo aquí tengo una
parte aquí tengo otra parte aquí tengo
otra parte ok y de igual manera puedo
hacer aquí puedo dividir a esto en la
mitad
ok y después esto a la mitad y esto a la
mitad de tal manera que aquí ya tengo al
entero dividido en 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
partes iguales o dicho otra manera cada
una de las mitades de este entero está
dividido en 4
partes iguales 1 2 3 4 y aquí también
tengo 1 2 3 y 4 ahora si yo salto del 0
para acá al llegar a este punto date
cuenta que en este momento me estaría
tomando una cuarta parte de este un
medio es decir que aquí en este punto de
aquí tendría un cuarto por un medio pero
no es lo que queremos lo que queremos
son tres cuartos por un medio así que
déjame cambiar de color y vamos a llegar
a tres cuartos por un medio y para eso
voy a saltar de aquí hasta este punto
otra vez ok
aquí llevamos un cuarto de un medio
ahora me voy a saltar hasta este otro
punto de acá llevo dos cuartos de un
medio y ahora me voy a saltar hasta este
otro punto de acá llevo tres cuartos de
un medio que es justo lo que yo quería
este punto de aquí y es más déjenme
ponerlo con otro color con el color
verde que va a ser nuestro resultado
este punto de aquí es justo lo que yo
quería este punto aquí es tomarme tres
cuartas partes tres cuartas partes de
un medio es decir tres cuartos por
por 1
me dio me tomé primero a este un medio
lo divide en cuatro partes iguales y de
estas cuatro partes iguales me tomé tres
de ellas tres cuartos por un medio y
bueno si te das cuenta este punto de kim
este punto de aquí representan tres
octavos si pensamos en todo el entero
completo lo tenemos dividido en ocho
pedazos iguales uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho y por lo tanto
este punto de aquí representa un octavo
un octavo aquí llegamos a dos octavos o
espera eso es un 1
aquí dos octavos ok y aquí estaríamos en
tres octavos en tres octavos es decir
que este punto aquí es tres octavos y lo
que quiero que te des cuenta es que esto
es congruente esto es completamente
cierto a comparación de lo que ya
aprendimos si nosotros recordamos lo que
vimos acerca de la multiplicación de
fracciones esto es exactamente lo mismo
que tomarme tres cuartos aquí tres
cuartos y aquí un medio un medio y esto
es lo mismo que tres por uno
entre 4 por 2 la multiplicación de los
numeradores entre la multiplicación de
los denominadores y esto es exactamente
lo mismo que 3 por 13 3 sobre 4 por 28
de lujo tres octavos ok llegamos a tres
octavos de una manera matemática de una
manera aritmética y de una manera visual
ahora qué te parece si pensamos este
mismo problema pero desde la otra
perspectiva es decir yo me voy a tomar
ahora tres cuartos tres cuartos de este
entero y después voy a tomar un medio de
esos tres cuartos ahora quiero que te
des cuenta que si tengo a este entero
aquí y lo quiero dividir en 4 me tomaría
una parte justo aquí aquí tendría una de
esas cuatro partes aquí tendría otra de
esas cuatro partes y aquí tendría otra
de esas cuatro partes de tal manera que
aquí tengo a un cuarto aquí tengo otro
cuarto y aquí tengo otro cuarto y justo
en este punto justo en este punto de
aquí llegaríamos a los tres cuartos
cuartos ok ya que tengo aquí a mis tres
cuartos lo que me quiero tomar es un
medio de esos tres cuartos y para eso
voy a dividir cada uno de los cuartos en
medios y si te das cuenta este cuarto ya
lo divide en medios es este punto este
cuarto ya nos divide a la mitad que es
este punto este cuarto y ya nos dividía
la mitad que es este punto y este último
cuarto también ya no dividía la mitad
que es este punto bueno más o menos y si
a continuación me quiero tomar de estos
tres cuartos un medio es decir la mitad
de este camino de tres cuartos pues voy
a llegar a tomarme un cuarto y medio es
decir un cuarto vamos a ponerlo así un
cuarto ok y medio y llegó justo al mismo
punto
si yo divido tres cuartos a la mitad
llegó de nuevo a tres octavos que es lo
que yo quería y bueno date cuenta que
este punto de aquí es tres octavos
porque tenemos el entero dividido en
ocho partes y camine una de esas ocho
partes vamos a ponerlos y una de esas
ocho partes dos de esas ocho partes
de esas 8 partes de lujo por lo tanto
tres cuartos por un medio que es
exactamente lo mismo que un medio por
tres cuartos ya puedo concluir que es
exactamente lo mismo que tres octavos y
ya lo vimos de una manera completamente
visual espero que me hayas entendido lo
importante de esto es que entiendas que
es lo mismo tomar tres cuartas partes de
un medio o dicho otra manera un medio de
tres cuartas partes